Okay. Let's do some questions, bro. We haven't done this in a while.
Let's do some questions. Um,
Oh, interesting. On episode 36, this is by Wade nine eight one zero.
On episode 36,
you answered a Twitter question about wearing sunglasses indoors and said it was
terrible.
Did you change your mind or did your future just get so bright that it became a
health hazard and you had to,
so I understand futures to bright futures, so bright.
See, I wear sunglasses indoors cause my future. But here's the deal, man.
You can kind of do anything as long as your attitude is like, you.
You know what I'm saying? Like I was thinking about this the other day.
Uh,
if you wear Tivas or Birkenstocks
or doc Martens,
like my point is if you wear some real corny.
Okay. And if you're wearing it,
because you're not thinking about what you're wearing and you're just like, Oh,
someone gave me those are all wear them or, okay, cool.
I'll put them on because they're convenient or they're comfortable then your a
dork. But if you legit think, Whoa Tivas are they?
And you're like, I know they're not in fashion,
but y'all because I think they're the. Then more power to you.
Most guys who wear sunglasses at night or indoors,
they're wearing them because they're insecure and they want to show you how cool
they are. But if you actually are like, y'all,
I'm going to wear these indoors because I'm a.
Then dude, that's some serious Jeremy Renner.
If you're wearing a long coat in the desert,
just because someone made you think it's a good idea,
then straight up.
But if you're wearing it because you think long coats are the and
short coats can go suck then honestly.
[Inaudible].
So there's no mind change in babies.
Now that doesn't mean that it doesn't change his mind.
No daddy changes his mind because changing your mind is all about growth in the
world changes. So you have to, when people are like, change,
that's crazy to me for life to continue to rip.
You have to keep changing. We grow every cell in your body.
Wasn't in your body about 10 years ago. They're all new cells.
And I think that that's true, probably because Neil Brendan told me.
So anyway. Yeah. That's some real.
Is there another question? Thanks for your question. Weighed nine,
eight one zero.
Austin Burns at Austin dolphins, crystal, Leah, thoughts on fantasy football.
I mean, so wants me to be favorable about it. Cause his name is dolphins in it.
Um, bro, my brother does fantasy baseball and.
And look, let we know.
Obviously there is absolutely nothing dark here than fantasy football.
Everybody knows. It's all good. And it's fine. And it's fine. It's all good.
Now is fantasy football dorky? Yes. Is it all good? Yeah,
don't do fantasy football and think it's not dorky. You know what? I'm a dork.
If you're doing fantasy football, you're basically the guy saying, well,
I just think it's interesting because the original,
the original comics that Wolverine had it,
he had a different outfit on and whatever, if they're going to update it fine,
but still stick true to the thing. But they're not really doing that.
And that's fine basically. That's what you're doing. If you're like, Oh, dude,
Tim, salmon's got some. So now I'm,
my is my teams on top.
Cause Tim salmon you're you're basically saying, look,
I just think it's funny that the jug or not, you know,
could go through walls and it's like, obviously he could be stopped,
but Nightcrawler, all he needs to do is take care of business.
And he's not doing that. This basically what you're doing is you're saying,
dude, I, I just think it's funny that, you know, Todd zeal,
Todd Ziel, obviously, he could do a little bit better, but he's not because,
because of the injury and it sucks because he's on my
he's on my fantasy team. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Oh yeah.
Todd seals on my fantasy team. No, he's not dude.
Todd's deals on the Cardinals and that's it now do I knew new players? No.
Isn't Molina a player.
The shortstop guy Moline is killing it. Cause he's, he's a shortstop. I'm a fan.
He's on my fantasy team. No, he's not. He's only on St. Louis.
He's only on the card knows Molina's not on your team. You know why?
Because Molina is not on your team. Number one and Molina is on St.
Louis number two and number three, you don't have a team,
A dark, it's a fantasy football, take a hike.
My brother will go like bro mom, my fantasy team is killing it. And I go,
Oh, I really, it doesn't matter. And he laughs because he knows dark.
You know?
W how about the dorkiest about the FA the fantasy football are the names that
people use for their teams.
It's like, that's the only thing. Worse than band names. Like sparkle, horse,
you know?
Uh, yeah.
W what is this people say, do you have people come at me? They say, Oh,
you don't have this. Hey, Chris, Leah, you're holding it.
The first four 41 episodes of congrats pod hostage.
How am I supposed to be attributed? We don't act as to all the baby things,
dude. They're up there. Look for them. They're all available, bro. Use Google.
What am I a grandma? A Scoble
anyway, dude. Um, what else?
Any other questions?
One fire says this one's funny. So if it's not
Congratulations pie, this is by gypsy 24, baby squirrel. K.
Obviously, you know, what's coming.
[Inaudible].
Uh, Oh, wow. Okay. Stagecoach new lineup again. Didn't they just do stagecoach.
I swear. Every two weeks. There's a new line of, for stage coach. Okay.
Let's click on it. Now get
the stage coat. You know what me off the stage coach font.
It looks like some old lady that font that they use is some, is the font,
the stagecoach font that they use,
the official stage [inaudible] font that they always see.
The word stage coach Inn is. So the font that a store would use,
that my mom would walk by and window shop at. All right?
Like what did it? I liked the, you see that, that you should get that for.
You should get that for your, your girlfriend. That's what my mom would do.
You should get that. You should get that for
you should get that for your aunt right there. She likes those kinds of things.
And Christmas is coming up. Uh,
these are the people California's country music dude.
Every two weeks is stage cause every two weeks
I already did this, but I guess it's funny. Thomas Rhett,
Brett young Dustin Lynch. I do. I can't believe these people's names, man.
I mean, as, as Netherlandish,
as the Netherlandish names are the stagecoach names are the stagecoach names.
I mean the guys name is Eric Church. Cerner legis,
Eric Church, Tim Pugh and Josh
pastor and Brian
Lord lover and Tim
hanging on cross
Tim hanging on cross.
Yeah.
Hey, what's up? I'm Tim hanging on cross.
Come on down the stage coach where we guarantee we use the fond that Chris's mom
will we'll stop. It is short storing and window shop
Thomas Rhett, Brett young destined.
Come on down to stagecoach where everyone's way too high. Come on, stand up.
Come on. Down. Set stage coach where everyone's name is [inaudible] all right.
We've got Thomas red here in the house. Brett young Dustin Lynch,
Billy Ray Cyrus, Morgan Wallen, Lil NAS X.
The only guy who doesn't have a white name is the only guy who's not white.
Anyway, we got Mitchell Tenpenny, Nicky lane. Of course Raelynn one word.
Of course. Hardy of course, Pam Tillis, Ingrid Andrus. The last bandoleros,
which is somehow wider, even though it sounds Mexican [inaudible] then,
then we have Willie Jones and Whitney. I can't believe these names,
dude. Carrie Underwood course, Dan plus Shay Midlands. Easy top low Kashi,
Teddy Ross, Courtney Marie Andrews, T Peyton Smith.
The guys in the littlest font are the best. I mean, dude,
the Hayden triplets. Oh my.
The hell he didn't triplets dude. So white. The whitest. I try. First of all,
it's so white to be triplets. Know what I mean?
Like if you have two more, you next to you, that's the whitest ever.
Wow.
Um,
I don't know what, uh, what else to it? Even say about that? How about the?
Do you ever see the picture? I got a tweet. This picture.
Why are there so many pictures of Vladimir Putin chilling so hard?
You Googled that mere Putin. You'll see them just like on a rock,
looking like it's his library, dude.
He couldn't be sitting more like he's in libraries, Eddie, everywhere. He goes,
he's chilling. Even when he's sitting on a horse,
he's just literally has a look of like, I have a library at my house.
These pictures are unreal. Um,
what else did we got pictures?
No of a room where you questions.
That's it? Do we have a no misconnections or whatever? Whatever, bro.
It's all good. Let me look at my texts and see who's got what? Let me see.
Who's texting me. I, I thing here,
guy writes, Hey, can I send you a shirt and a beanie?
Uh, man, I don't know. I'm writing.
I don't really like beanies that much,
that much.
And every time I'm texting this guy back time,
someone sends me a shirt.
It seems like it would fit only
a child. I've got to keep it real, man. There you go.
Aiden just texted you back, dude. I gotta keep it real. I can't,
I can't front.
There's this weird thing that's going on in comedy. Um,
and uh, it's like,
it's this thing where like people want to like the cause the left
is being so pussified that these comedians want to
quote unquote, tell it like it is.
And that's becoming really increasingly annoying,
like any reaction to something that's so drastic is also annoying.
So like there's this thing where it's like,
some comedians are really good at it. Like bill Burr, Chris rock,
Dave Chappelle. They do the telling it like it is at the,
it meets the funniness, but some comedians are like, bro,
I just got to keep it real and tell it like it is.
And they do it so hard that they're not being funny as well.
Like that should never be the forefront I've been thinking about this man.
So many comedians are trying to tell it like it is that it isn't being
funny.
And then there's enough people in the world that will like you,
no matter what,
if you have some sort of fan base because there's 7 billion people out there
that some people will just be like, Hey man, props to you for keeping it real.
No, not props to that person for keeping it real stop keeping it real may funny.
I don't want to keep it real even though, you know, that has got to keep it real
because this he's the two Parker comedy, but really be funny.
That's why I always say we're done for a silly goose time and that's it, man.
I don't want you to mistake me for one of those.
That's always telling it like it is bro.
Keep in mind, always underlying,
but also onstage silly goose time.
You got to mix the with the,
because if you just have the, then you won't have enough,
but what we're really looking for is,
you know what I'm saying?
Does that make sense for a hearing aid for a hearing aid for an audio aid?
Does that make sense to you?
It's not enough to just keep it real. Be funny.